hello and welcome to New World review
where today we have happy dogs happy
intelligent dogs do you want to see a
happy intelligent dog we have them we
have them all that and beanies do we
have beanies yet Liam fantastic job Liam
I knew we kept you around for very good
reason if you love it Liam's editing and
enjoy this content hit that like button
I record these reviews and just send
them to him so anytime Liam does
something funny he kind of deserves some
appreciation but not too much
appreciation I've seen some of the
photos he's pulled out of the vault some
of those photos deserve the dislike
button in my opinion not too much
dislike but enough to know the buttons
there you know who you are let's discuss
episodes 21 and 22 this week's first
episode was the end of the arc
it was a clear signing off of the first
storyline we had some questions posed we
had set up for the next arc and we got a
callback to the first phase of the exam
it was serviceable actually it was
pretty good was gone always that strong
did I miss something is alumi in need of
absurd amounts of calcium hmm Murray's
gone suddenly stronger did he hit a
milestone I felt lost in that moment I
knew his bone had broken when I heard it
break but that may be the first
indication of Gaughan having super
strength it's also an interesting point
as well as there his soccer hitting him
yes Gaughan has shown great fortitude
he's been hit and got up when people
have told him to stay down he's been
strong enough to stay standing and to
carry others when they're weak oh wait
let's go back to that I thought that was
a metaphor before the idea that he could
carry all of them at once no child can
carry that many people no child could
carry one people their children gone has
always had super-strength but he's a
child in fact looking back I'm doing my
own retrospective now looking back gone
pulled a big old fish from the water way
back in episode 1 again I dismissed that
information as hyperbole I just thought
yeah nice action sequence the fact that
his strength is being used here though
it hints at darkness especially since
there's an assassin standing and
watching him do it to him it Lumi why
speaking of halloumi why did he not
attack gone or remove himself from gone
he reached out why what was he going to
do we know he wouldn't kill gone because
of his relationship with his Soaker but
he didn't attack in order to disable
which he very well could have done
before green smiley frogman's
Epton artistically you would think in
that moment that we would have stepped
into either a thought sequence or an
action sequence but neither happened
instead we stayed firmly in the moment
if slowed alumi slow movement was a huge
and immediate indicator to go on which
is why he jumped back but we've seen
alumi attack much faster and with much
more laziness he's also attacked with
more deliberateness to him such as when
he psychologically attacked Kela is it
possible that alumi has a little fear
for our teeny strong man the reason he
could attack Kiowa psychologically or
physically was because he didn't fear
cure kill was his brother he's not a
threat
he could be disabled with words gone
doesn't have that weakness more in fact
he has a sense of purpose around him
that says he wants to protect his friend
I do wonder what would have happened if
it had come to an attack an assassin's
primary method of attack is often
surprised but gone has spent time with
kill one believed him without hesitation
when Kela said he came from a family of
assassins there's no element of surprise
here for gone unlike a looming the
interaction between these two and Hisoka
is also interesting Hisoka casually sits
in the background of this entire
exchange and while the other characters
are there too when illumined gone was
seen together I couldn't help but notice
my love his Sokka sitting up the back
watching the expression on his sokka's
face during the end of the last episode
and the beginning of this one was of
calm satisfaction
Hisoka had no concern for gone despite
the danger he was in facing up to a
clearly accomplished assassin yes he's
made it through the first part of the
exam apparently and he's a hunter but
the importance of Ghana's prey with
regard to what his soul Kerr said to
Korra pika
why do I suspect that had something to
do with protecting gone I don't know why
but that's my suspicion I'm sticking to
it I know we'll come back to it later so
I'm not too concerned with it for now
but it is a moment of interest it's the
only thing those two really have in
common their love for gone if it had
been anything to do directly with his
backstory could época would have lost
control of himself it's too much of a
trigger point for him let's discuss his
sokka's private sexytime I was
apparently right he's waiting for our
boy gone to mature so he can go hunting
I suppose it's hunting season with the
hunting hat pipe and rifle and his Sokka
is ready to get to him he just has to
wait for his child to come of age I
really don't know how else to phrase
these things y'all I'm sorry it's just
so Oh
I'm trying to be sensitive about the way
his oak is portrayed but it's like
they've taken a character from less
mainstream anime as it were and put him
into a kid's cartoon it's somewhat
baffling and then they sat on the man
who has been with them from the
beginning the man who speaks from under
a mustache the man who in fact may not
be a man but instead be a mustache with
a static body softened by a boy with a
broken arm why is the tots I quite like
the character I like the fact that he's
been watching over them the entire time
so far it gives me hope that we'll have
another peripheral character who will
turn up from time to time especially
since Khan's father was mentioned and so
Todd specifically declared his love for
the man Khan's father is someone to
discuss - we can't find him yet he's a
main quest point let's stay on these
rails and continue the journey to the
next stop next stop cluck cluck town
chicken mill Oh
Mountain I said it I was close we have
to find Kela let's do it as to be
expected when we closed off one arc this
was the setup and beginning of the next
one I'm going to call it the chicken
ville arc because it's easier for me to
say then cuckoo cuckoo big mountain big
scary one could argue volcano since it
seems like smoke not storm cloud that
hovered around the peak let's get closer
on that we have new characters we've
been introduced to the butler of the
household the idea that a family of
assassins has someone who protects their
interests is actually a really
intelligent and enjoyable one especially
a butler who looks like an assassin who
could probably use the coin he's
throwing to like shoot people and head
or something
I appreciate the aura he's putting out
into the universe there's a badass hurry
to it that I wish I could have and it
sets more of the tone of where Qi is
from and sets up the level of oddness he
would had to go through just to begin to
make friends the level of space and
status involved in the huge doors is a
great one I really appreciate the Greek
call out the door to Hades is a lovely
image especially with the idea that in
order to get anywhere you have to be
able to open the door the killer only
opened three doesn't mean he couldn't
open more but it gives us a little
insight into his thoughts when he
returned if that's the case there was
something in door or world 3 that he
very specifically wanted
go to or use to find some kind of maybe
solace apparently that's the equivalent
of his cell and he's gone there to
ponder his behavior or else that's his
room it depends on the effect illumi had
on him as to why he went through door 3
and I love that the different levels of
Hell would mean something very specific
to each person who crosses into it Mieke
in that first level reminds us of course
of Cara Bruce that cute puppy of the
underworld gone is afraid immediately
and I'd like to consider that for a
moment what we got was a gleam of purple
the way they've set up the series thus
far when we see purple we're going deep
into thought processes
we're in someone's mind whose depends on
context in this case the context of the
Hound suggests it's Gon's mind gone is
overwhelmed by the power and thoughts of
the Beast and realizes he doesn't want
to fight it and that that is a very good
choice the effect Myka has on gone is
the same one almost that illumi had
ancilla is the first indication we have
of the world being different darker more
psychologically driven especially since
we just saw a last episode that Illuma
didn't frighten gone with his energy as
a huntsman and a nature-based person gan
could read Micah's energy and that was
scary that said we know how gone reacts
to creatures he's scared of he wants to
conquer them enjoys the rivalry and
enjoys the thrill of it his fear
inspires caution but not enough to avoid
the thing he fears it's enough instead
usually to step towards it and that's
what I expect him to do here what if
we're in Micah's mind however what if
he's reading gone and makes a decision
whether he appreciates the boys
psychopathic tendencies he clearly
doesn't see Khan as a threat in dog body
language you don't lie down like that
when you see a threat the fun thing is
that having puck the dog I can't have
some insights into animal behavior and
movement and reactions paka only lies
like that when he doesn't particularly
feel threatened it's a readied lying
position dogs know they can stand faster
than humans mechanically they're just
more capable of quick movement Mika has
a great deal of intelligence I don't
think Gahan is afraid of Micah's
physical abilities he's afraid of the
intelligence in Micah's eyes an assassin
house with assassin family with an
assassin dog who can take the
psychological measure of its prey that's
concerning and it should be concerning
Gahan is here to rescue Kiawah from his
emotionally abusive family being a
psychopath doesn't change that what
might change that is the fact that for
the first time gone maybe
realizing that he's not the only
psychopath being a psychopath is only of
benefit in dangerous situations where
you have to make decisions
out-of-the-ordinary compared to the rest
of society guess what gone is in a
situation now where others are
psychopathic can and will use and abuse
him they don't look at him as a child
they look at him as prey and they judge
him based on who he is not what he does
we don't see karapa coyly audio's
reaction to mika because we don't need
to it's assumed that they're afraid it's
assumed that they're having ordinary
human reactions the extent kora pika and
the audio are capable the important one
here is gone in his reaction to finding
out he can't assume anyone will treat
him differently because he's a child
he can't smooth talk his way past this
creature the way he spoke to honza or
SATs
the creature would understand his speech
but has judged him based on energy and
what's behind his eyes and that is scary
for a preteen with a fishing line and no
really solid concept of the use of
emotions he's out to rescue Kela but
it's still hard to believe that he's out
to rescue Kiel Wafaa Kiowas benefit his
behavior suggests he's out to do it
because of his ownership of Kela he had
fun with the kid assassin but to eerily
complement each other and so this is the
arc we're going to pursue I'm ready for
the dark and the grit and the
psychological trauma bring it on but not
right now because that's it from me if
you enjoyed this video and please do
leave this video a like share or
subscribe and if you'd like to join the
fund and please do head over to the
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on episodes 19 and 20 of
Hunter hunter this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time